atteindre des centaines de personnes
vulnérables dans les zones rurales
un défi majeur pour la campagne de
vaccination en ouganda le lac boni yayi
se trouve dans le sud ouest du pays
parsemé d'îles seo abrite quelques 2500
habitants
c'est l'un des endroits les plus
difficiles d'accès du pays notamment
pour le personnel médical basé sur l'île
de batz noir pour chaque action de
proximité que nous faisons ici ou nous
devons traverser le lac
chaque patient qui vient ici doit aussi
traversé le lac
cela signifie que sans utiliser de
bateaux vous ne pouvez pas accéder aux
centres de santé et aux services
médicaux
cela nécessite plusieurs choses l'argent
ou alors d reçoit son carburant si vous
n'avez pas d'argent vous ne pouvez pas
vous déplacer pour recevoir des soins
atteindre les îles environnantes
implique une traversée au moins de 30
minutes en bateau soit sur un canot et
traditionnelles ou à bord d'un bateau
moteur bien plus coûteux les vaccins
sont ainsi transporté au travers du lac
dans une simple glaciaire une avancée
néanmoins pour cette zone qui ne
disposait pas de fonds suffisants pour
débuter une campagne de vaccination au
centre de santé bien ma 3 il n'avait pas
encore commencé la vaccination contre le
colis de 19 alors que le gouvernement
l'a lancée le 10 mars mais le district
nous a expliqué que le transport
constitue une limite car les vaccins
doivent être acheminés depuis le
district pour qu'un bateau fasse un
aller-retour pour venir jusqu'ici cela
coûte la somme de 28 dollar est
effectivement une telle somme n'est pas
à la portée de tous
la pandémie de kovy 19 a rendu la
situation encore plus difficile pour les
habitants de l'île lesquels compte en
temps normal sur le tourisme comme
source de revenus l'exercice à bas noir
a permis à plus de 200 personnes de se
faire vacciner dès mercredi premier jour
de la distribution
les autorités espèrent vacciner mille
personnes parmi les plus vulnérables sur
ces îles selon les chiffres officiels le
pays déplore seulement près de quarante
mille cas pour plus de 334 décès